More than 35 years after the release of its
low-budget, outrageous first installment in
1981, Evil Dead is still alive.
With four movies and a TV series under its
banner, the franchise just can't beaten.
Here's how this crazy, campy, chainsaw-happy
movie about one guy taking on demons in a
remote forest cabin went from the backwoods
of Michigan to the delirious nightmares of
horror fans worldwide.
Three schmoes
The film was willed into existence by one
essential trio: actor Bruce Campbell, director
Sam Raimi, and producer Robert Tapert, though
none of the three had those titles when they
came together to start their project.
They were instead, in the words of Bruce Campbell,
"three schmoes in search of a clue."
Unbeknownst to all of them, they were destined
for a long future together, and it all started
with a series of low-budget Super 8 films
they made together in college.
After cobbling together a catalog of shorts,
the three started thinking about producing
a full-fledged feature, and in 1979, Raimi
came up with a story about some kids who accidentally
summon evil spirits from a sacred burial ground.
Within the Woods
To make their horror project, which they wanted
to name The Book of the Dead, the trio first
finished a short film as a proof of concept,
calling it "Within the Woods."
With a budget of $1,600, they shot the half-hour
movie over the course of a three-day weekend.
Then, they set out to find investors to make
the full-length film.
The only problem was that nobody knew who
they were.
To make up for their lack of credibility,
they staged what Campbell estimated were hundreds
of screenings of "Within the Woods," picking
up a dollar here and there.
After months of work the trio came up with
$85,000 — not nearly enough to finish the
movie, but enough to get started.
Pain and celluloid
Knowing money was tight, the trio was merciless
when it came to keeping costs contained.
To get a shot of the camera breaking through
a window, they just shoved the camera through
a real window, while another guy smashed the
window with a two-by-four to break the glass
before the lens touched it.
According to Campbell:
"When all else failed, we just taped the damn
camera to Sam's hand.
The opening shot of Evil Dead consisted of
me pushing Sam in a rubber raft across a swamp
while he leaned out, skimming the camera across
the water and swooping over decaying branches."
That wasn't the only time the actors had to
suffer indignities for the film — not by
a long shot.
One actress lost her eyelashes while making
a plaster mold of her face.
Others were mercilessly scratched up by branches
in the woods.
Mosquitoes swarmed to the Karo corn syrup
that the crew used for blood.
At one point, Campbell sprained his ankle
on set, and Raimi took to whacking the busted
ankle with a stick before takes to get a better
performance out of him.
Wild success
An "overnight success" is rarely as simple
as it sounds, but that's exactly what the
movie's producers had their hands on.
The finished film became a sensation thanks
in large part to some well-timed support from
horror author Stephen King, who wrote a review
for the movie in Twilight Zone magazine.
There, he called it "the most ferociously
original horror film of the year."
The filmmakers eagerly capitalized on this,
getting permission to use the quote on every
advertisement they could.
Raimi can't overstate how important this was
for their success, saying that King's endorsement
"opened the doorway for the film to be seen."
Dead by Dawn
Sam Raimi's next film was 1985's Crimewave,
a goofy crime comedy that completely failed
to make a dent at the box office.
After that failure, the trio decided to return
to their roots and make a sequel to their
first feature: Evil Dead II: Dead by Dawn.
A bigger budget and the backing of a studio
didn't alter the filmmakers' DIY methods.
Most effects were made with the same low-budget
approach, and there was no shortage of suffering
on the set this time around, either — though
a lot of the burden fell on one unfortunate
performer: the director's brother, Ted Raimi.
In a foam body suit, Ted portrayed the possessed
old lady, and he was so hot inside all the
foam and latex that he was constantly sweating.
As Bruce Campbell pointed out, in one scene
you can see a stream of sweat pouring out
of the suit.
Army of Darkness
In the five years between Evil Dead II and
its sequel, Sam Raimi filmed his first major
studio movie, Darkman, which was successful
enough to get him enough funding from Universal
to bring life to the third installment in
the franchise, Army of Darkness.
This time, instead of sticking with the cabin-based
shenanigans of the first two movies, our hero
Ash travels back to medieval times to fight,
well, the Army of Darkness.
Unfortunately, creative differences plagued
the movie's long road to a theatrical release.
Thanks to a dispute between Universal and
one of the film's producers, the film sat
on the shelf for a year.
Afterward, the studio decided to do a major
recut of the movie.
According to editor Bob Murawski, "They didn't
really understand it, they thought it was
too long, and didn't respond to a lot of the
funnier stuff."
The ending in particular was a point of contention,
with the studio wanting something more optimistic.
One intended ending had the series hero, Ash,
accidentally waking up in a post-apocalyptic
future, but it was axed for being too sad.
This resulted in the filming of a new ending
sequence, set in the present-day S-Mart after
Ash makes it back to his own time and dispatches
one final demon.
Which was still pretty awesome.
Modern-day Ash
In 2013, all three of the original schmoes
— Campbell, Raimi, and Tapert — produced
the Evil Dead remake, with newcomer Fede Alvarez
directing.
Although fans and critics alike were mostly
pleased with the remake, there was still one
thing everyone wanted: more Ash.
As Sam Raimi described it: "[Fans] really
loved [the 2013 remake], and I loved it.
But afterwards, I still heard that, 'Now we
want your Evil Dead with Bruce' [...] I didn't
know if I had much to gain, but they were
so insistent we finally said, 'All right,
let's just do it.'"
Along with his brother Ivan, Raimi finally
began work on another, Ash-centric installment
of the franchise, eventually landing on the
idea to do a TV show.
It was a natural fit, with the Evil Dead crew
having worked extensively in TV on the fantasy
show Hercules: The Legendary Journeys.
The future
Since it debuted in 2015, Ash vs. Evil Dead
has been a hit with both audiences and critics.
In a lot of ways, there's never been a better
time to be a fan of this series.
So what's next for the franchise?
In the wake of Alvarez's remake, there was
some talk about doing a crossover movie that
would collide the two franchise universes,
bringing Ash into the orbit of the remake's
characters.
Plans for such a project are apparently on
hold, although when asked about the crossover's
chances on Twitter in 2016, Campbell stated
that it's still "entirely possible."
And it's true — when it comes to this enduring
horror show, the sky's the limit.
To think that such a little film, originating
out of the deep woods of middle America through
sheer force of will, would continue to have
such an impact is pretty remarkable — or,
as Ash would put it…
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!